encuentra la pendiente de una recta
perpendicular a la recta 3 x 2 igual a 6
entonces si yo tengo una línea hagamos
unos ejes aquí
ese es mi eje y y ese es mi eje x y
supongamos que tengo una recta aquí que
tiene una pendiente m así es que la
pendiente de esta recta es igual a m y
una recta que sea perpendicular a esta
va a ser una recta que la va a
interceptar en un ángulo de 90 grados
así es que esto se va a ver así esta es
la recta perpendicular y este es un
ángulo de 90 grados y la pendiente de
esta recta no lo voy a probar aquí lo
haré en otro vídeo pero la pendiente de
esta recta va a ser igual a menos el
recíproco de la pendiente de la recta
original es decir está pendiente es
igual a menos 1 entre la pendiente de la
recta original es decir menos 1 entre m
habiendo establecido esto si podemos
calcular cuál es la pendiente de esta
recta simplemente calcularemos el
negativo del recíproco de esa pendiente
y tendremos la pendiente de la recta
perpendicular calculemos entonces la
pendiente
escribamos la ecuación aquí y la manera
más fácil de hacer esto es despejar y
para llevar la ecuación a la forma de
igual a mx más b y determinar por
inspección cuál es el valor de la
pendiente eliminemos entonces las x del
lado izquierdo restamos menos 3 x ambos
lados restamos menos 3 x ambos lados y
del lado izquierdo los términos en x
desaparecen me queda 2 y del lado
derecho me queda menos 3 x más 6 ahora
dividimos entre 2 a ambos lados de la
ecuación dividimos entre 2 en este caso
ambos términos del lado derecho y nos
queda de igual a menos 3 medios de x
este término aquí es menos tres medios
más 3 entonces la pendiente de la recta
que nos dieron esta pendiente la podemos
identificar fácilmente ahora que hemos
llevado la ecuación a la forma pendiente
ordenada y es igual a menos tres medios
esa es la pendiente así es que la
pendiente de la recta perpendicular a
ésta va a ser el negativo del recíproco
de este valor así que el negativo de un
valor negativo va a ser positivo y el
recíproco de tres medios base
a dos tercios así que el negativo del
recíproco de menos tres medios es dos
tercios positivos y ya hemos concluido
esta es la pendiente de una recta que es
perpendicular a esta recta de aquí